bonsoir et bienvenue dans savoure
regardera vite vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir La France est-Elle
prête en cas de conflit militaire à
l'heure ou notre pays livre de nouveaux
canons César à l'Ukraine on va
s'interroger ce soir sur l'état de nos
forces armées l'opinion hier dans un
article a donné des chiffres qui ont de
quoi faire peur si notre pays était
confronté à un conflit de haute
intensité il ne pourrait tenir que 80 km
de front pas plus comment en est-on
arrivé là le budget de la défense est-il
à la hauteur grand débat dans un instant
avec nos invités privilège blanc
intersectionnalités
notre grand témoin ce soir déconstruit
méthodiquement la pensée wok dans un
film et vous le verrez c'était différent
ça s'appellera 6e une histoire
franco-américaine ce sera diffusé lundi
soir sur LCP pour y voir plus clair sur
cette idéologie qui séduit les jeunes le
réalisateur Michael prasant va nous
présenter son documentaire ce soir enfin
nos affranchis ce soir le parti pris de
Brita sunberg du Spiegel les colère et
Moretti vue d'Allemagne le mot de la
semaine de notre sémiologue Mariette
tarigan le travail et puis les archives
de Brandon Noiret les rentrées
parlementaires chahutés tout ça n'a rien
de neuf vous verrez voilà pour le menu
c'est parti
[Musique]
en cas de guerre la France ne tiendrait
qu'un front de 80 km c'est un pavé dans
la mare que l'enquête de l'opinion signé
Jean-Dominique Mercier et publié hier on
va s'y attarder ce soir alors où les
députés examinent le budget de la
défense et ou la France continue d’armer
de façon importante les Ukrainiens
bonsoir général trinquant ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau ancien chef de
la mission militaire française à l'ONU
bonsoir Emmanuel Dupuis ravi de vous
accueillir président de l'Institut
prospective et sécurité en Europe
spécialiste de ces questions bonsoir
Adrien Gomy député renaissance de
Seine-et-Marne et membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères et le
député insoumis de Seine-Saint-Denis
Bastien Lachaume nous rejoint dans un
instant il est membre lui de la
commission de la défense on va
s'interroger sur nos capacités nous
défendre parce que franchement tout ce
qu'on entend à quoi vraiment faire peur
mais d'abord on va revenir sur et bien
notre aide à l'Ukraine avec vous
Stéphane dakovski si j'ai bien compris
elle ne faiblissent pas c'est à vous
tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
messieurs si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam notre
beau pays la France est montré du doigt
par la presse internationale au motif
que on ne fournirait pas assez d'armes à
l'Ukraine alors l'accusation elle vient
de la BBC à un article publié cette
semaine vous voyez qui dit que la France
fait sorte de boudisco on les connaît
c'est français en revanche tandis que 2%
des armes livrées à l'Ukraine donc c'est
vrai que quand on regarde le résultat de
ce classement le top 10 des pays qui
font qui donne de plus d'armes à
l'Ukraine où est la France mais elle n'y
est pas Madame en Kawa mais onzième à ce
classement des livraisons d'armes alors
ça m'étonne parce que les canons César
nouvelle livraison de canon viennent
d'arriver en Ukraine c'est le président
Macron qui l'annonce les canons César de
santé frémir nos Experts le canon qui
fait la fierté de l'artillerie française
on en a déjà livré 18 à l'Ukraine
apparemment les Ukrainiens savent les
utiliser puisque on voit bien qu'enfin
l'armée russe beaucoup beaucoup d'images
recul et d'ailleurs puis on parle des
Russes ils ne sont pas tout à fait
d'accord avec l'analyse de la BBC eux
ils disent pas oh il ne livre pas assez
d'armes ils disent mais vous en livrer
beaucoup trop d'ailleurs notre
ambassadeur et régulièrement convaincu à
Moscou pour que Ben pour le sermonner
comme ça se fait de manière diplomatique
alors pourquoi nous sommes si mal
classés
question mais pourquoi on tient pas
notre rang donc c'est la question des
députés de l'opposition on posait un
Sébastien Lecornu le ministre la défense
pourquoi la France n'est pas dans le top
10 et donc la réponse du ministre c'est
en fait ce classement il est bidon et
pour trois raisons donc première raison
on parle uniquement de quantité le
général vient de dire qu'on part du
poids des armes livrées en fait dans ce
classement et donc ça suffit pas de
livrer du poids il faut livrer des armes
de qualité c'est ça qui réclame les
Ukrainiens ensuite
il y a des gens qui sont livrés de
manière secrète donc forcément elle ne
figure pas dans le classement et il y a
aussi une troisième raison qui explique
que ce classement et bidon et cette
troisième raison n'est pas jolie jolie
troisième des choses il ne tient compte
en général que ce qui est promis et non
effectivement livré et là une fois plus
j'en dis pas plus pour ne pas créer
d'incident avec nos amis et alliés enfin
il y a une réalité c'est que à l'unité
près ce qui a été promis a été donné aux
Ukrainiens alors très concrètement le
ministre de la Défense moi je crois que
ce sont les Anglais et les Américains
mais ce que je constate en tout cas
c'est que les alliés qui soutiennent
l'Ukraine on pense à s'accuser
mutuellement de ne pas faire assez
d'effort donc par exemple les
Britanniques nous montrent du doigt et
alors nous qu'est-ce qu'on fait et ben
on montre du doigt des Allemands parce
que les Allemands ils ont des chars très
performants dès le je crois léopard ça
s'appelle voilà donc ils hésitent aux
Ukrainiens donc Nathalie Loiseau qui
représente la France au niveau européen
elle dit oh là là les Allemands limite
elles traitent de poule mouillée en
écoute
la contre-offensive ukrainienne a
démarré et obtient des résultats c'est
vraiment maintenant qu'il faut continuer
qu'il faut augmenter les livraisons
d'armes je souhaite que la France fasse
plus je souhaite clairement que
l'Allemagne fasse beaucoup plus alors
l'Allemagne si on a besoin de plus vous
voyez effectivement mais cette émulation
entre pays ça peut être positif non
alors oui effectivement en ce moment
quand on s'intéresse à ce débat sur les
livraisons on se rend compte qu'il y a
quand même un petit climat sur enchères
dans le monde il y avait une tribune
publiée le mois dernier ou un expert
militaire disait mais que nous a demandé
aux Allemands de le faire livrons-nous
nos chars Leclerc aux Ukrainiens alors
moi qui découvre le dossier je vois des
sourcils qui se lèvent sur le plateau
on va tout leur donner aux Ukrainiens
parce que regardez il y a un rapport
parlementaire ça ça nous concerne qui a
été publié au début de l'année et
l'armée française n'est pas non plus si
bien équipée par exemple en terme de
munitions on nous dit si on est attaqué
au bout de quatre jours on n'a pas de
munition donc on finit par se demander
messieurs des experts est-ce qu'à force
de donner nos armes à l'Ukraine on va se
retrouver à s'affaiblir nous-même
une excellente question
les armées françaises sont faites
pourquoi pour défendre la France et les
citoyens français donc le premier
objectif du président de la République
et des armées c'est de mettre les armées
françaises à niveau pour défendre notre
pays notre pays aujourd'hui notre pays
rappelons simplement que pendant 20-25
ans à peu près il y a une baisse des
budgets de la défense chaque chaque loi
de programmation militaire qui dure 5
ans perdait une année sur 5 depuis 6 ans
la loi de programmation est en
augmentation un milliard 7 tous les ans
à partir de 2023 finalement
le général Pierre de Villiers avait
raison quand il a il a poussé son son
gros coup de gueule qui affiche
pour pouvoir augmenter qu'il avait peur
qu'il baisse bon ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est que cette
augmentation était faite dans un
contexte qui n'était pas la guerre en
Ukraine la guerre en Ukraine c'est une
guerre de haute intensité et le chef
d'état-major des armées après alerté il
y a deux ans et la
les études stratégiques montrait que il
fallait s'attendre à ce qu'à un moment
un pays puissant puisse attaquer ou
menacé et donc il faut bien garder à
l'esprit que les armées françaises c'est
fait pour ça ça c'est le premier point
ça pose la question de l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut parce qu'on
est quand même Emmanuel Dupuis peut-être
un tournant on nous dit que personne
pourrait tomber que la contre-offensive
ukrainienne progresse 400 km², est-ce
que c'est maintenant qu'il faut
continuer l'effort d'aide militaire
massif pour que les Ukrainiens peut-être
remporte d'ici cet hiver cette guerre il
faut pas l'arrêter il faut le continuer
mais il faut surtout pas l'arrêter parce
que on aurait presque le sentiment que
les administrations ou les critiques sur
le fait que nous livrions trop d'armes
comprise au sérieux non il faut
évidemment continuer l'effort on a fait
référence à une étude qui a été
largement commentée par un expert
français qui évoquait des chiffres qui
peuvent évidemment paraître non pas
anecdotique très inquiétant nous serions
que le raison de 2 % dans l'ensemble
rapport au livraison par rapport aux 49
il met en avant en fait des chiffres et
un institut de recherche donc allemand
l'évoque 230 millions c'est ce qu'avait
Sébastien Lecornu sur l'officiel contre
les 25 milliards américains mais ça où
il oublie quand même un certain nombre
d'éléments premièrement que nous
contribuons à hauteur de 20% de la
facilité européenne pour la paix qui est
le bras armé de l'Union européenne qui
fournit par ailleurs sous l'égide de la
politique de sécurité défense commune de
l'Union européenne du matériel que qui
sont utilisés de la même manière que nos
18 Césars que nos quarantaines de
véhicules bastions et que peut-être
demain donne Leclerc c'est un sujet de
préoccupation ensuite nous contribuons
18% du budget de l'Union européenne et
donc des facto nous sommes un acteur
majeur de la résilience ukrainienne le
président Macron je crois la répéter
hier au Château de Prague à travers
peut-être une nouvelle structure à
travers j'espère une nouvelle structure
la comité politique européenne comme
quoi il faut protéger notre territoire
être prêt à protéger le pilier oriental
de l'OTAN je rappelle que nous assommons
depuis l'année 2022 le commandement de
la force de réaction rapide et que nous
sommes nation4 dans deux pays en Estonie
en Roumanie et dernier point il est
aussi important de fournir les armements
que de permettre aux Ukrainiens d'être
suffisamment entraîné pour pouvoir
utiliser cet argument cet armement
pardon et cet argument c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous sommes très influx
impliqués dans le financement d'une
opération et UTM une opération de
d'équipement d'entraînement de l'Union
européenne bonsoir Bastien Lachaud et
bienvenue sur ce plateau je le disais
député insoumis de Seine-Saint-Denis
membre de cette commission de la défense
d'accord avec ce constat on continue il
faut continuer à armer les Ukrainiens
parce que c'est décisif il y a un moment
de bascule et en même temps il faut pas
non plus être alarmiste sur l'état de
nos forces
être à l'armiste sur l'état de nos
forces c'est c'est un bien grand mot ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui c'est en effet
continuer l'aide aux Ukrainiens et
prendre les mesures
compensatrices parce que on le voit à
force de donner du matériel de haut
niveau et qui on l'a vu avec les Césars
fait clairement la différence
de vendre du matériel on a vendu des
rafales à la Croatie à la Grèce et bien
on a affaibli notre notre outil
militaire aujourd'hui et
malheureusement je dirais le budget
2023 n'est pas à la hauteur de de la
situation
je voudrais rester un tout petit peu
encore sur le terrain ukrainien drainant
mis aujourd'hui l'info du jour ce sont
les mots Joe Biden le président
américain a extrêmement voilà je sais
pas si c'est volontaire mais il est très
alarmiste puisque je le cite il alerte
sur l'apocalypse nucléaire pour la
première fois depuis le début de froide
c'est la première fois qu'il parle comme
ça pourquoi le fait-il selon vous il y a
un risque fort je pense qu'il a il a
raison de le souligner si vous le
permettez j'aimerais revenir juste une
seconde sur cette histoire de classement
et spécialiste l'ont dit je pense que le
ministre Sébastien Lecornu lorsqu'il dit
en effet qu'il y a une différence entre
les promesses et ce qui est livré c'est
une vérité au-delà de l'article de de
l'opinion ce que vous faisiez ce à quoi
vous faisiez référence sur la facilité
européenne de paix qui n'est jamais pris
en considération dans les classements et
qui est de 400 euros je pense que c'est
bien compris tout dépend voilà tout
dépend de l'outil de l'outil de mesure
sur Joe Biden oui j'ai écouté avec
attention les propos qui sont les siens
il est à l'armiste en même temps il faut
bien reconnaître que la situation elle
est également qu'on voit que les sorties
de Vladimir Poutine sont toujours plus
excessives les unes que les autres il
faut faire front ça prouve une chose
c'est que l'attitude de la majorité
présidentielle et du gouvernement depuis
le au début du conflit
ukrainien contrairement à certaines
oppositions a été claire très claire il
faut soutenir les Ukrainiens il faut que
la réponse soit là au niveau et là je
voudrais vraiment essayer de comprendre
d'interpréter les mots de Joe Biden soit
il considère qu'en gros Poutine a déjà
perdu et que c'est la fuite en avant
vers le pire et il nous avertit parce
qu'après tout elle les Américains ont
toujours dit ce qui allait se passer en
amont soit il est en train de négocier
ou de préparer les esprits alors je
pense que il y a deux choses la première
il rentre dans ce qu'on appelle le
dialogue dissuasif
qui est cet entretenu avec lui qui lui a
dit on sait ce que vous préparez
attention
Poutine a été assez fou pour y aller
parce qu'il croyait dans ses fantasmes
de prendre Kiev en trois jours sans
combat il a perdu il sait pas comment se
récupérer ça ne doit pas se terminer par
par des frappes nucléaires au passage on
compare et le président Biden compare à
Cuba je rappelle qu'à Cuba ça s'est bien
terminé les Russes sont les Russes
reculées
est importante et je crois que Joe Biden
pour l'instant la maîtrise d'ailleurs
c'est la première fois qu'il en parle
habituellement
le porte-parola c'est un degré
supplémentaire parce que Vanina Poutine
dans son discours du 22
du 22 septembre
quand il a reconnu elle est les enfin la
semaine dernière voilà les quatre
républiques à évoqué le fait que la
Russie ne souhaitait pas utiliser la
nucléaire mais que ça faisait partie de
sa doctrine engendre en juin 2020 elle a
précisé que si le territoire et c'est
marqué dans les textes donc stratégique
russe que si le territoire russe était
agressé il pourrait utiliser l'arme
tactique maintenant je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec Dominique quand vous voyez
des images d'un train nucléaire quand on
laisse fuer l'information sur lequel on
va tester la fameuse torpille Poséidon
qui n'est qu'au stade expérimental vous
savez cette fameuse torpille qui
pourrait selon les turifères de du
Kremlin provoquait un tsunami d'ailleurs
il l'appelait à ce qui est une frappe
sur les côtes anglaises pour que Londres
soit comme ça totalement submergé ça
fait partie encore une fois d'une montée
en puissance et d'une descente quand
ramsam kaderov évoque son souhait selon
lui le président d'utiliser un nucléaire
tout de suite après Maria zagareva la
porte-parole dit c'est une chose
sérieuse pour que ce soit digéré et puis
ensuite on revient au terrain de la de
la France que même si le décidait ne
serait pas suivi par la hiérarchie
militaire alors est-ce qu'on entend les
critiques et de plus en plus ouvertes
ils sont ils sont trois il y a lui
ministre de la défense et le chef
d'état-major et ces trois-là les deux
autres plutôt qui sont des des vassaux
de Poutine sont en très mauvaise
position en ce moment et est-ce que eux
se diraient bah écoutez on va pas jouer
cette catastrophe parce que c'est notre
fin de toute façon assurée c'est avoir
et puis je dis toujours que l'arme
nucléaire ça va du bout à la fin de la
fin de la chaîne puisqu'on parlait de
Cuba petit incident intéressant à Cuba
l'ordre avait été donné d'envoyer une
torpille nucléaire et c'est le
sous-marinier qui n'a pas appuyé sur le
bouton donc si vous voulez il y a quand
même une chaîne qui est long
divers et variés alors la France
maintenant est-ce qu'elle est prête à
une guerre de haute intensité parce que
dans ce contexte la question doit se
poser Sébastien Lecornu le ministre des
Armées a été auditionné avant-hier ici
même à lAssemblée nationale il annonce
un rattrapage important des efforts
suffisants ou pas c'est toute la
question on va d'abord tout cela avec
les avantaga
dans le budget 2023 la défense c'est
43,9 milliards d'euros plus 3 milliards
par rapport à 2022 une mobilisation
exceptionnelle de moyens selon le
gouvernement pourtant la situation de
l'armée française est loin d'être
parfaite dans un article de l'opinion le
spécialiste Jean-Dominique Mercier
évoque même des chiffres qui font peur
si la France était engagée dans un
conflit semblable à celui que subit
l'Ukraine l'armée pourrait tenir un
front de 80 km seulement la France ne
serait pas suffisamment armée en cas de
conflits intensité alors quels sont les
faiblesses de l'armée française de la
vue du gouvernement elle a connu pendant
de nombreuses années un manque
d'investissement si on prend les lois de
programmation militaire depuis
1971 on va arriver à un budget
historiquement haut du budget des armées
ça augmente et ça comble le retard il
suffit de visiter un régiment il suffit
de se rendre à Toulon à Brest pour voir
dans une base aérienne celle d'Évreux au
hasard pour voir que ça con un retard la
France a choisi un modèle d'armée
complet terre r marine qui exerce des
missions différentes opérations
extérieures sécurité nationale
dissuasion nucléaire de grandes
ambitions donc un de ces défis et celui
du recrutement il y a aussi la question
de l'artillerie la France dispose par
exemple de 76 annonces Césars elle en a
déjà livré 18 à l'Ukraine pour les
suivants elle les prendra dans une
commande réservée au Danemark impossible
de puiser à nouveau dans ses provisions
la France doit aussi reconstituer son
stock de munitions 2 milliards d'euros
ils seront consacrés l'année prochaine
enfin question technologies la France
accuse un retard sur les drones moins
2000 sont à sa disposition
3000 sont promis cette année
pour le chef de l'État et chef des
armées la guerre aux portes de l'Europe
a confirmé la nécessaire monter en
puissance de l'armée française
doit poursuivre mais ce n'est pas un
sacrifice c'est un investissement
qu'elle consomme pour elle-même
le niveau de cet effort nous oblige tous
mais je veux ici nous rappeler cette
phrase du général de Gaulle la défense
c'est la première raison d'être de
l'État
il n'y peut manquer sans se détruire
lui-même une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire est prévue pour
2024 2030 elle devra prendre en
considération cette nouvelle donne
géopolitique
il y a beaucoup de choses sur cette loi
de programmation militaire j'aimerais
bien déjà avoir votre avis sur les
fameux 80 km de l'opinion en général
trinquant alors je vais vous donner un
avis de quelqu'un qui était
qui s'occupait des plans d'opération du
deuxième corps d'armée avant 90 qui
était dans la réserve du groupe d'armes
centre et à l'époque nous avions un
front de 80 km pour faire quoi pour
mener une contre-attaque donc ça dépend
pour faire quoi 80 km 80 km
au maximum de ses capacités elle peut
tenir que l'île
la terminale GI militaire est
extrêmement précise
moi je vous parle d'offensive donc si
vous voulez avoir un rapport de 5 à 1
face à la première armée de la garde
pour la nommer par exemple et ben vous
vous mettez sur 80 km donc je ne sais
pas d'où les chiffres sortent de ce
journaliste de cette conversation mais
ce que je peux dire c'est que ça n'est
pas précis 80 km de quoi pour faire quoi
ce qui a de certains ce qu'il faut
vraiment les distances
l'Ukraine la frontière le principe
l'offensive à Cardiff à votre avis elle
était sur combien a été sur 10 km de
front d'accord et c'est ça qui a permis
d'enfoncer l'armée russe donc pour vous
c'est quoi c'est une forme de sabotage
des esprits sur les forces que l'on a de
faire ça d'écrire ça oui écrire ça est
extrêmement dangereux dans un journal
tout public parce que ça ne prend pas
des données qui sont des données
extrêmement précises je voudrais
rappeler simplement que l'armée
française dans le cadre de du combat en
toute intensité n'a jamais envisagé de
le faire en dehors de l'OTAN
je jouissité les années 90 on n'était
pas intégré à l'époque et pourtant on
était la réserve de l'OTAN on a toujours
été dans le cadre de l'OTAN et
aujourd'hui l'OTAN compte sur quoi sur
la France fournissant un corps d'armée
avec une division
une division dure j'allais dire
françaises et elle compte la France
aujourd'hui sur Terre on s'entend comme
son premier allié en Europe on parlait
tout à l'heure des armements
britanniques qui sont fournis les armes
mon britanniques terrestres ils peuvent
les fournir ils sont en train d'abattre
un tiers de l'armée de britannique donc
forcément ils ont des armements
a compris que Bercy a serré la vie
pendant trop d'années et que ça a été
tellement douloureux pour nos armées que
le rattrapage est compliqué Bastien
Lachaud de quoi manque-t-on le plus vous
qui êtes dans la commission de la
défense
de tellement de choses on moque de
matériel et on moque de
des chars des danses roquettes des
avions de chasse tout ça déjà on manque
de stock on manque de stock de munitions
on manque de stock de petits matériels
tout cela c'est une réalité cela remonte
en puissance c'est c'est indéniable les
budgets ont augmenté nous manquons de
gros matériels nous avons deux vendu des
rafales aujourd'hui l'armée de l'air n'a
pas récupéré sa capacité ce qui pose un
certain nombre de problèmes notamment
pour les hommes qui opère ses armes qui
n'ont pas les durées d'entraînement
nécessaires pour être au maximum de
leurs capacités et donc on a un
véritable problème humain derrière
justement et de logistique et de soutien
donc un problème matériel on a compris
un problème humain un problème de
recrutement comment on répond à ça il y
a un problème de recrutement il y a un
problème de formation aussi il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup d'éléments moi ce
que je retiens dans les propos qui ont
été tenus précédemment c'est que là on
fait face à une augmentation de 36%
d'autorisation d'engagement alors bien
sûr on peut dire que ça ne suffit pas
dans tous les cas il y a eu un il y a eu
un changement dans le budget dans le but
il y a une augmentation du budget ce qui
était fait j'ai bien compris votre
journaliste faisait référence à ça
il y a 6 ans il y a eu un véritable
virage en faveur je le pense d'une
augmentation d'un budget de la défense
44 milliards exactement pour pour 2023
une augmentation de 36%. on a une loi de
programmation militaire qui va se qui va
se préparer dès le début de l'année
prochaine on voit que la précédente
était déjà assez assez ambitieuse moi ce
que je retiens et je souhaite qu'on voit
les choses de cette manière là bien sûr
il y a la défense française mais il y a
aussi tout ce que l'on mène à
l'intérieur de l'auteur mais aussi à
l'intérieur de l'Union européenne on a
vu pendant la présidence française de
l'Union européenne avec la mise en place
de cette boussole stratégique c'est très
important de compter et dans je pense
notre défense à l'intérieur de la
défense européenne que nous appelons nos
vœux on a du mal à savoir quand même je
comprends bien qu'il y a différents
échelons de défense qu'on n'est pas tout
seul donc on a des alliés mais est-ce
qu'on est prêt en cas de conflit de
haute intensité est-ce que l'armée
française est prête cette vraie question
qui préoccupe ce qui nous regarde alors
je vais faire référence à un rapport
parlementaire qui je crois et assez bien
rédigé pour répondre un partiellement à
nos questions au-delà de l'article que
vous auquel vous faisiez mention mention
c'est évidemment le rapport de vos
collègues Patricia miriès et Jean-Louis
therriot qui évoque un certain nombre de
lacunes les drones les hélicoptères de
combat lourds les avions de transport
hors gabarit et un certain nombre de
matériels dont nous avons loupé tel des
étapes l'investissement ça c'est une
certitude maintenant tout le monde est
évidemment
convaincu qu'il faut une accélération
pas tellement le nom de matériel dont
nous avons c'est la capacité à être plus
rapide c'est que les industries un
tournoi plein les investisseurs on a
plus 3 milliards ça vous semble
suffisant c'est pas une question de
c'est pas une question c'est pas une
question c'est une question
d'accélération si vous considérez que un
César met une année pour être construit
qui n'en sort trois ou quatre par mois
et que c'est le cordul a dit que l'armée
française devrait en avoir 42 plus
au-delà de ce qu'on est en train de
cannibaliser je rappelle que on a
calibalisé partiellement les 36 qu'on
devait donner au Maroc et les 19 qu'on
va donner au danois
Danemark là-bas cannibalisation ça veut
dire qu'on prend des pièces dessus
je me je me corrige en tout cas ça veut
dire que on doit tenir sur plusieurs
fonds premièrement ce dont on a besoin
pour nous ce qu'on va exporter et ce
qu'on va donner aux Ukrainiens et donc
du coup c'est une question
d'accélération de cadence le délégué
général à l'armement
pour le coup c'est là où les 2001 vont
servir si on met 9 mois pour construire
un système d'arbre évidemment si le
conflit va durer longtemps il faut qu'on
puisse livrer plus rapidement le
matériel dont nous allions ont besoin
d'accord en fait oui mais juste un point
le 23 février qui pensait qu'il y aurait
la guerre en Europe donc l'accélération
et la commencer il y a 6 ans au pas
auquel les finances publiques pouvaient
se permettre etc là on se rend compte
que la guerre oui c'est possible c'est
là mais on parle de la France mais tous
les pays européens sont dans le même cas
et la France est moins mal placée que
les autres pourquoi le chancelier
allemand a dit je mets 100 milliards sur
la table parce que l'armée allemande est
dans un tel état de déliquescence qu'il
a besoin d'augmenter les seuls qui ne
sont pas dans cette situation ce sont
qui les Américains parce qu'ils ont des
stocks considérables et aujourd'hui les
Américains fournissent beaucoup
d'armements pourquoi parce qu'ils
avaient des stocks prépositionnels en
Europe et que leur industrie
il y en a plein pour fournir tout ça les
autres Européens qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fourni ils ont fourni pour l'essentiel
d'anciens matériels de l'époque de
l'occupation de l'Union soviétique que
les Ukrainiens étaient capables de
servir tout de suite on se rassure
Bastien lachachebourg ce débat qui
s'achève je voudrais qu'on l'ouvre sur
la question de de notre armée et de et
du service militaire peut-être est-ce
qu'il faut changer une armée
professionnelle dans ce contexte où la
sécurité menacée est-ce que c'est
toujours adapté déjà ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est que l'armée française est
la seule vraie armée opérationnelle
européenne on est la seule armée capable
d'entrer en premier sur un territoire
etc etc donc il ne faut pas regarder que
l'aspect négatif
non on n'a pas de mal à recruter c'est
faux il n'y a aucun problème de
recrutement les armées remplissent leurs
objectifs de recrutement tous les ans on
a un problème de fidélisation
c'est-à-dire que les soldats à la fin de
leur premier contrat ne le renouvelle
pas c'est une raison
des problèmes de rémunération des
problèmes de logement des problèmes de
etc etc des problèmes de de soutien de
vie et cette plus que de d'entrer dans
le
dans la carrière militaire donc ensuite
on a un souci de flux c'est à dire un
souci de flûte nos industriels capables
de suivre le rythme d'une d'un conflit
de haute intensité parce que nous
n'avons pas fait suffisamment le soutien
à la base industrielle et technologique
de défense depuis suffisamment longtemps
et aujourd'hui en effet il y a la guerre
sur le continent européen et que fait le
gouvernement il maintient le cap de la
LPM précédent la loi de programmation
et
j'entends le problème c'est que ces 3
milliards sont déjà grignotés par
l'inflation quasiment la moitié de ces 3
milliards et absorbés par l'inflation on
a l'augmentation du point d'indice qui
ramasse encore 400 millions et tout cela
n'est pas ajouté allez donc suffisant on
a bien compris dernière petite question
très politique peut-être aux experts
j'imagine que vous serez satisfait vous
êtes dans la majorité Sébastien Lecornu
c'est l'homme de la situation est-ce
qu'il est suffisamment marées il a l'air
d'adorer la défense il va falloir tenir
tête à Bercy c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire il adore la défense il a toujours
rêvé être à ce ministère là il aime
beaucoup ça c'est déjà une grande
qualité parce que souvent on a un
ministre qui adore la défense quand il
s'en va parce qu'il a découvert la
défense là il adore quand il rentre
dedans espérant qu'il l'adorera tout le
temps comme ça non je pense que c'est
l'homme qu'il faut pour ce type de de
mission pour conclure le mot de la fin
j'aurais pas tout à fait les mêmes mots
que Dominique mais je crois que
Sébastien Lecornu a une qualité c'est
qui s'est écouté les experts que sont
les militaires et qui sont en train de
préparer la prospective possible d'une
guerre de haute intensité je rappelle
que il y a un notion consubstantielle à
la guerre d'intensité c'est de gagner la
guerre avant la guerre c'est-à-dire de
la faire et ça je crois que le militaire
l'ont convaincu merci merci beaucoup
pour vos éclairages respectifs et
d'avoir participé à ce débat on va à
présent accueillir notre grand témoin et
les réalisateurs et écrivain il vient de
signer pour LCP un film qui va faire
réagir c'est sûr une histoire du walking
mais de son cortège de mots souvent
obscur intersectionnalité privilège
blanc qu'un seul coltcher né aux
États-Unis importés en France ses idées
cette idéologie à une influence
redoutable dans la jeunesse et même
au-delà Michael prasant signe ce
documentaire il nous rejoint juste après
l'invitation ce soir signé Clément Méric
auteur et réalisateur lauréat de
nombreux prix vous avez signé Michael
prason une douzaine de livres et une
vingtaine de documentaires consacrée
entre autres au nazisme à la Shoah ou au
stalinisme dans racisée vous nous
plongez d’abord dans les racines
françaises du walkisme avec le concept
de déconstruction portée par Deleuze
Foucault ou Derrida aux États-Unis la
pensée de Foucault de Derrida de Deleuze
et de Bourdieu va être vu comme au
contraire une manière d'enraciner les
individus dans leur communauté d'origine
ou dans leur orientation sexuelle et à
partir de là le contresens va être
complet vous montrer comment ce courant
de penser a pu conduire à des dérives
dans certaines universités américaines
[Musique]
privilège blanc intersectionnalité ou
quand celles culture vous expliquez
comment ces concepts ont traversé
l'Atlantique via les campus les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi Netflix ou Disney
jusqu'à faire irruption dans notre débat
public est-ce que vous avez jamais tenu
ou tolérer des réunions en non-mexicains
lors de votre bureau national de l'UNEF
la question est simple donc très bien
laissez-moi expliquer mais vous montrez
aussi que nos débats actuels ne sont pas
si nouveau en 1972 Romain Gary pique une
colère quand on lui reproche de mettre
sur un même plan le racisme des blancs
et le racisme des Noirs le représailles
raciste au nom du racisme c'est de la
connerie la plus dégueulasse que
l'humanité est jamais connue et noir
jaune tchao grec au latin ou merdeux à
part entière c'est un raisonnement que
je n'accepte pas d'Elisabeth Badinter à
Pascal Bruckner en passant par Rachel
Kahn dans ce documentaire vous vous
tournez vers les tenants de
l'universalisme français pour définir le
walkisme un parti pris assumé mais dans
quel but
bonsoir Michael présentoir Myriam ravi
de vous accueillir sur ce plateau racisé
une histoire franco-américaine s'est à
découvrir lundi soir à 20h30 en direct
mais c'est déjà en ligne donc dès ce
soir vous pouvez regarder ça sur le site
de la chaîne LCP.fr et sur la chaîne
Youtube delcp alors pourquoi ce film et
pourquoi pour vous il était important
voire même urgent de déconstruire des
déconstructeurs
parce que déjà il faut expliquer ce qui
se passe et je crois que tout le monde
ne le comprend pas nécessairement
surtout quand on appartient à des
générations un peu plus un peu plus
ancienne
les boomers notamment c'est pas du tout
leur imaginaire et c'est pas du tout
leur vocabulaire et ces nouveaux
concepts méritaient d'être expliqué et
puis aussi d'expliquer d'où ils viennent
comment sont-ils venus jusqu'à nous et
c'est quand même une histoire où l'on
court il faut remonter à la fin des
années 60 au début des années 70 pour
comprendre ce qui se passe et ça se
passe essentiellement dans deux milieux
purement américain c'est-à-dire le le
contexte de la lutte pour les droits
civils des Noirs américains
tout au cours des années 60 et puis
l'arrivée de la French théorie sur les
campus américains c'est-à-dire ces
philosophes ou co Deleuze Derrida et
puis ensuite Bourdieu qui vont être
récupérés à l'aune des névroses
américaines si vous voulez y compris
finalement c'est ce que vous montrez
dans une dévoyez presque c'est un
malentendu c'est un dévoiement c'est une
récupération à l'aune disons d'impulsion
et de nécessité propre
à la situation de la société américaine
qui est elle-même entièrement fondée sur
la question de la race et sur la
séparation des races alors justement
pour répondre à la question qui vous est
posée par par Clément Méric dans ce
petit sujet pourquoi vous avez donné la
parole quasiment contenant de
l'universalisme républicain Elisabeth
Badinter Pierre-Henri tavoyot Rachel
Kahn tous ceux qui sont clairement aux
antipodes de cette pensée racialiste
alors il faut pas juste parce qu'il y a
quand même un professeur américain qui
s'appelle yorhuru Williams mais les
autres sont plus présents pourquoi ce
choix ce parti pris c'est un choix déjà
parce que c'est ma fibre je veux
expliquer j'ai pas voulu faire un pas en
flèche j'ai pas voulu non plus prendre
de haut ces nouvelles théories si on
veut qu'il nous arrive ici mais en même
temps je ne veux pas de complaisance
avec ces théories et j'ai voulu revenir
à la source c'est à dire quitte à avoir
un discours wok je préférais que ce soit
quelqu'un qui soit ancré dans cette
réalité américaine et qui donc lui-même
est américain il est noir il est
ancienne saignant vous savez de ces
African American Studies aux États-Unis
et il a une parole qui pour moi est
authentique nous sommes en France dans
une espèce de copier-collé si vous
voulez qui fait fi de toute réflexion de
toute contextualisation on se contente
de prendre des mots-valises qu'on
traduit littéralement sans même se poser
la question de savoir s'ils sont adaptés
à nos sociétés à nos propres situation
et donc je préférais cette parole là
avec laquelle je suis parfois en
désaccord personnellement très souvent
d'ailleurs en accord parce qu'il a une
parole encore une fois qui est ancrée
dans cette situation américaine qui
n'est pas la nôtre je tiens quand même à
le préciser et puis enfin les tenants
wok si on veut
de se en France s'exprime beaucoup dans
le film mais il s'exprime dans les
images d'archives et donc on réagit et
d'ailleurs il y a des désaccords que je
joue sans prendre parti mais enfin ma
fibre c'est l'universalisme et c'est
cette floraison d'intervenants qui sont
dans le film mais qui pour la plupart
sont tous mes amis alors le film s'ouvre
sur une scène saisissante effrayante
même Evergreen ce campus universitaire
de l'État de Washington progressiste de
gauche qui va décider en avril 2017
d'instaurer un jour d'absence plutôt une
journée d'exclusion des blancs pour
soutenir les étudiants noirs inquiets de
se sentir mal venu après l'élection de
Donald Trump regardez ses saisons
[Musique]
voilà ce n'est plus une discussion tu
n'as pas le droit à la discussion le
professeur qui tente de s'opposer à
cette journée d'exclusion racontez-nous
c'est brathwanstein il a dû démissionner
une fine qui est un professeur de chimie
qui appartient au camp progrès
systeméricain c'était un fan de Bernie
Sanders donc c'est pas non plus un
dangereux fasciste comme d'ailleurs
c'est dit par un certain nombre
d'étudiants qui le traite de nazie donc
c'est c'est hallucinant et laisser cette
séquence est totalement hallucinante
effectivement inaugurale
il va être obligé de quitter le campus
et il ne pourra pas y revenir parce que
un certain d'étudiants ont fait la
chasse à ce qu'ils appellent les
suprématistes blancs dont il serait le
faire de lance dans cet université et
cherche albastonnet à coup de de battre
de baseball donc il n'a pas pu rentrer
sur le campus il a donné sa démission
et voilà l'histoire cette arrêtée là
mais enfin cette histoire des vergreen a
eu lieu en 2017 et aux États-Unis on a
des ever green quasiment toutes les
semaines aujourd'hui en France ce genre
de scène à l'université parce que vous
dressez en parallèle net vous dites nous
ne sommes pas comme la société
américaine la question raciale n'est pas
du tout aussi prégnante qu'aux
États-Unis et en même temps il y a eu
l'affaire Sciences Po Grenoble le
professeur allemand klauskinsler accusé
d'islamophobie par ces étudiants qui a
été suspendus est-ce que c'est au fond
l'affaire Evergreen française pour vous
c'est ce que je vous l'ai dit je mets en
parallèle puisque j'ouvre le
documentaire pas révergreen et je finis
le documentaire par effectivement
l'affaire de l'IEP de Grenoble et
l'affaire Klaus Kinsler évidemment il y
a des points communs indéniable y
compris dans la manière dont ça se passe
si vous voulez après il y a
effectivement des différences mais ça
montre aussi la force du soft power
américain qui vraiment imprègne les
nouvelles générations en gros les jeunes
gens jusqu'à 25 ans sont les cibles
privilégiées de cette idéologie qui
passe par différents relais alors ça
peut être des séries télévisées ça peut
être des influenceurs ou des
influenceuses sur Internet qui passent
d'ailleurs sous les radars un peu de des
générations plus anciennes et qui ne
voient pas ce
phénomène se répandre parmi ces jeunes
gens et puis ça passe aussi par
l'université par les départements
sociologiques principalement mais aussi
par un certain nombre de grandes écoles
et les IEP Sciences Po sont extrêmement
imprégnés de cette idéologie donc il y a
pas de hasard alors évidemment il y a
des contrefeux sans doute qu'il n'y a
pas aux États-Unis mais ça gagne dans la
société surtout dans cette génération il
y a une intervenante dans votre film que
j'aimerais qu'on entende son témoignage
est assez fort et même très touchant
elle s'appelle Assita Kanko elle est
députée belge au Parlement européen il
regarde regardez j'ai lu 6 mois de
Beauvoir j'avais 11 ans pourquoi parce
que j'étais obsédée par la liberté je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi je t'ai traité
différemment en tant que fille pourquoi
à l'âge de 5 ans j'ai été j'ai été
excisée pourquoi je devais faire toutes
les tâches ménagères je me posais
beaucoup de questions et j'ai découvert
un passage de de d'un livre de Simone de
Beauvoir qui m'a intrigué je n'ai pas
tout compris la première fois mais ce
que j'ai compris c'était une chose
qu'une femme qui n'a même pas ma couleur
de peau qui habite dans un pays que je
ne peux pas situer sur la carte donc
j'ignorais l'existence parce qu'un stage
là pour moi il y avait que le Burkina
Faso qui existait on était à la campagne
on n'est pas de télé on avait la radio
RFI mais je savais pas d'où ça venait
moi RFI
alors à ce moment là je crois qu'il n'y
a rien de plus universel que ça que la
liberté ça existe dans un langage qu'on
comprend même si on est différent et
c'est grâce à cette femme à Simone de
Beauvoir à son livre que moi j'ai
compris que j'avais le droit d'être
libre et que j'ai également compris
qu'on pouvait se battre pour la liberté
pas seulement pour soi mais aussi pour
tout le monde dans la société quel
témoignages Assita concours est une
femme extraordinaire qui lutte
réellement pour les droits des femmes et
les droits humains très concrètement
voilà c'est une figure totalement
universaliste et elle en parle en
fonction de sa couleur de peau elle le
dit ça fait du bien entendre quand même
au nom de cette couleur là et elle dit
je suis une personne je suis à Sita
point voilà et c'est vrai que la couleur
de peau en tout cas dans la manière
d'interpréter l'idéologie walk fait
écran et et en fait se nourrit de
présupposer racistes en réalité puisque
on définit la personne d'après en
fonction d'une binarité excessive
d'ailleurs puiser chez des philosophes
ou des penseurs français tels que
Bourdieu le dominer le dominant et c'est
la couleur de peau qui devrait décider
au fond à la fois de notre destin et en
même temps d'une culpabilité ou d'une
innocence a priori non ça ne fonctionne
pas comme ça la couleur de peau est un
indicateur mais en aucun cas elle ne
définit la personne et assis takanko est
là pour nous le rappeler d'ailleurs elle
a écrit des livres aussi où elle défend
ce qu'elle ce qu'elle présente ici
puiser de son histoire personnelle donc
il y a une forme d'authenticité
imparable dans ce qu'elle dit un autre
élément dans le film j'aimerais qu'on
s'y attarde un instant c'est une forme
d'impasse d'impossibilité de la pensée
wok à reconnaître les juifs comme des
victimes à leur donner ce statut là et
vous soulignez d'ailleurs le silence des
walkistes après les attentats contre
l'hyper cacher pourquoi alors déjà pour
moi personne n'être une victime par je
veux dire c'est pas parce qu'on a telle
ou telle couleur de peau ou qu'on vient
tel milieu qu'on ait une victime a
priori donc déjà moi je réfute si vous
voulez le postulat après c'est
effectivement étonnant parce que les
Juifs étaient si vous voulez après la
guerre
l'archétype même de la victime mais ils
ne le sont plus parce qu'entre temps il
y a eu Israël Israël est un marqueur de
l'extrême gauche d'une idéologie
progressiste comme on pourrait l'appeler
aux États-Unis et les Juifs sont
totalement assimilés au destin d'Israël
éventuellement à sa politique
donc ils sont passés si vous voulez
suivrepticement ou ou très rapidement en
fait à partir 77 du statut de victime de
dominer à dominant et et le problème si
vous voulez c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
nouvelle victime doit être le musulman
et c'est vrai que une vieille femme même
rescapé du camp d'Auschwitz dès lors
qu'on l'a tue ou qu'on la défenestre et
bien à partir du moment où cette
attentat ou cette assassinat est commis
par
lui qu'on suppose être la victime quel
que soit son comportement d'ailleurs a
priori c'est-à-dire le musulman et bien
le Juif est embarrassant il ne peut pas
être pris en compte comme une victime à
part entière quel est le rapport à la
violence de ces mouvements quand ils
deviennent politiques ces mouvements
walkistes vous avez cette phrase dans le
film vous comparez walking et maoïsme
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour moi
énormément de points communs c'est la
jeunesse innocente et d'ailleurs
ignorante qui vient faire la leçon aux
anciennes générations qui au mieux peut
accepter leur autocritique et si ça
dépend le cas la relégation absolue
alors pas nécessairement quand de
travail dans nos sociétés démocratiques
mais par la cancer culture et bien on
interdite parole on interdit de droit au
fond de d'être dans la société un
élément qu'on considère comme un pur ou
qui aurait dérapé d'ailleurs hors de
toute contextualisation bien souvent du
propos qui est tenu donc il y a cette
pulsion si vous voulez épuratrice
totalitaire il faut régler son compte au
fond y compris à la langue à l'histoire
etc donc il y a une volonté revancharde
extrêmement violente qui s'exprime à
travers cette idéologie très rapidement
il y a rien à sauver à vos yeux dans le
film il est pas si loin du mouvement
MiTo bien sûr qu'il n'est pas si loin
des mots comme le féminicide par exemple
qui permettent de faire avancer ce
combat là alors tout ce qui peut faire
avancer les consciences et le bienvenu
il y a des choses qui sont très
intéressantes dans le walkisme en termes
de constats dès lors que ça peut nous
aider à progresser à pointer du doigt un
certain nombre de zones nombre de choses
qui sont comment dire régressifs tel que
le racisme dans la société le mode
d'intersectionnalité est intéressant
mais comme le dit très bien d'ailleurs à
chez le cas à partir du moment où ça
devient un dogme où on attend telle
parole de telles proposition d'un
individu qu'on a considéré comme tel ça
devient problématique dernière petite
question je voulais autre commentaire
sur
par le prix Nobel de littérature pour
toute son oeuvre
l'écrivaine en même temps elle n'a
jamais caché son soutien au ce qu'on
appelle décoloniaux est-ce que ça vous
inspire un commentaire ou pas ça
m'inspire assez peu de commentaires
parce que je l'ai jamais lu alors je
fais confiance
au comité Nobel pour le fait qu'elle est
sans doute et peut-être et certainement
et je l'espère un grand écrivain pour le
reste et prise de position je l'ai
partagé pas merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup Mickaël prasant lundi soir
20h30 racisée une histoire américaine et
une histoire française je suis sûre que
vous allez apprécier cette
déconstruction de toute cette novlang à
laquelle on ne comprend pas toujours
grand-chose vous restez avec moi Mickaël
on va accueillir à présent nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ce soir
c'est le parti pris de Brita Sandberg
qu'on va accueillir brittenberg du
Spiegle sciez Alexis colère et Eric
Dupond-Moretti étaient allemand est-ce
que faire aurait été géré de la même
manière le mot de la semaine de Mariette
d'Harry grand notre sémiologue adoré ce
soir c'est le travail et puis les
archives de Brandon Noiret les rentrées
parlementaires chahute pas d'hier nos
affranchis les voici bonsoir bonsoir à
vous trois Brita Sainte-Barbe on est
ravi de vous accueillir correspondant à
Paris du Spiegel vous vouliez revenir
sur les affaires en Allemagne type à
faire colère ou à faire Dupont-Moretti
depuis l'Allemagne on regarde ça comment
d'une façon beaucoup plus sévère je vous
ai fait une petite sélection des
scandales politiques que nous avons vécu
au courant des dernières années et qui
lustre bien que la France et l'Allemagne
définissent le terme d'une République
exemplaire d'une façon quand même assez
différente une des affaires la plus
importante était par exemple celle
autour du président allemand qui faisait
partie du Parti conservateur Christian
Wolf et à une bonne dizaine d'années
déjà en décembre 2011 la presse
allemande dévoilée que vous le savez
accepté un crédit privé de
on lui reprochait aussi d'avoir accepté
les invitations pour passer des vacances
sur une île dans la mer du Nord et une
autre reproche qui avait évoqué beaucoup
de réactions étaient celles que sa femme
avait profité pendant quelques mois
d'une voiture qu'on lui avait mise à
disposition à des conditions favorables
et le même concessionnaire de voiture
avait fait cadeau au fils de Wolf d'un
bobycar vous savez c'est les petites
voitures en plastique rouge pour les
enfants qui ont peut-être une valeur de
150 euros
l'imagine et là du démissionner de son
poste à la présidence les République
deux mois après une autre affaire en
Allemagne concerne le ministre de la
Défense un des ministres de la défense
était de très populaire jeune 41
grande espoir du Parti conservateur
c'est les ou de Angleterre que tu es
soupçonné d'avoir copié des parties de
synthèse de doctorat avoir copié
d'autres publications sans l'avoir
mentionné comme il faut le faire
normalement dans ce genre de
publications scientifique un professeur
de droit avait trouvé plusieurs de ces
passages copiés en février 2011 deux
semaines après les premières relations
Gutenberg a donné sa démission en tant
que ministre et c'était vraiment la fin
de sa carrière politique et il était
quand même
en question que c'était éventuellement
lui qui aurait pu être le successeur
potentiel Angleterre en Allemagne il y a
un autre ministre aussi de la défense
concernée ce cas là joue entre autres
dans une piscine et c'est encore une
fois un ministre la défense comme vous
avez dit qui est au centre de cette
affaire où doivent charping
social-démocrate charping s'est fait
photographier dans une piscine d'une
villa privée à Majorque pendant l'été
il était avec sa nouvelle petite amie
mais pendant en même temps les soldats
allemands se préparer pour intervenir en
Macédoine et ces photos d'un ministre la
défense qui s'amuse publiquement pendant
que les soldats partent en combat n'ont
pas du tout plus au public allemand très
sévère et
certainement déjà mené tout de suite à
cette émission s'il y avait pas eu
l'attaque en septembre
aux États-Unis la table terroriste
finalement ce garshude qui a mis fin à
ce ministre l'été suivant et sharping
avait entre temps accepté les honoraires
d'une agence de relation publique en
plus donc c'était aussi la fin de sa
carrière alors quelle leçon abrita
sanbergues nous inviter à tirer avec
cette sélection se frôlent de faire en
Allemagne les Allemands sont beaucoup
par leur culture politique beaucoup
moins patients beaucoup moins indulgent
avec leur poste personnel politique et
les paramètres pour un comportement
exemplaire sont beaucoup plus stricts
plus et ça j'aime chez nous les
réactions à la fois de l'appareil
politique comme juridique sont beaucoup
plus rapides est-ce que c'est l'émission
qui sont exécutées très rapidement sont
toujours justes ça je crois pas
c'est parfois certainement se réagit
aussi selon la pression exercée par les
médias et le public allemand
davantage en politique c'est ça je crois
que c'est bénéfique la culture politique
aux règles sur le fait de surveiller nos
politiques et leurs dépenses vous voulez
dire d'exiger davantage d'exemplarités
ou en tout cas d'avoir
vis-à-vis des comportements une
intransigence qui fait que moindre
soupçons s'en va oui globalement je suis
d'accord avec ça après il y a un certain
nombre de réactions aussi qu'on peut
mettre bon encore une fois quand ça
devient une forme de système
alors on enchaîne avec vous Mariette par
exemple vous allez choisir un mot comme
chaque vendredi on a beaucoup parlé des
retraites l'assurance chômage étant
débat ici même à l'Assemblée forcément
votre mot de la semaine c'est le travail
voilà le travail et je vais essayer de
dire ce que je pense de ce travail
c'est-à-dire que c'est un mot magnifique
et qu'il faut absolument le réhabiliter
alors il nous pose plein de questions
difficiles il faut dire travailler plus
ou pas est-ce que le télétravail est bon
pour la santé ou pas j'ai pas du tout la
réponse mais je sais que ce mot doit
être réouvert pourquoi on l'aime pas ce
mot on l'aime pas à cause d'une fausse
étymologie ah tripalium voilà tout le
monde connaît cette étymologie populaire
comme on dit mais je pense que c'est une
sacrée fake news en fait alors pourquoi
mais parce qu'en fait si vous voulez
elle a été inventée par les moines du
Moyen-Âge en gros pour évidemment faire
passer l'idéologie du travail comme
rédemption donc travailler plus pour
mourir plus mais c'est pas grave après
on va revivre et puis c'était déjà là tu
enfanteras dans la douleur et où ça dans
la salle de travail Myriam on ouais dans
la salle de naissance c'est quand même
fou donc il y a des raisons idéologiques
mais quand on fait de la linguistique la
phonologie on se pose des questions
parce que le train va de le tri va
donnera le pallium ça marche pas donc
les linguistes actuelles on remis en
cause cette étymologie populaire alors
quelle est la véritable origine de ce
mot il faut remonter beaucoup plus loin
dans la langue dans ce qu'on appelle les
racines nindo-européennes c'est pour ça
que
dans toutes les langues en allemand
aussi donc le travail en réalité c'est
c'est une racine très qui est aussi bien
toute travel en anglais le voyage donc
c'est tout à fait une autre idée mais
qui est avec cette racine on s'élance en
allemand la pulsion pulsion de vitrine à
Die fraude je sais pas si je prononce
bien mais donc c'est un élan vital c'est
ça l'origine du mot tout à fait autre
chose effectivement autre chose donc ce
que je veux pointer c'est là-dessus que
je vais finir mais le travail ça n'est
pas forcément la souffrance c'est la vie
c'est un élan vital c'est une manière de
nous élancer on n'a pas besoin d'être en
activité quand on dort travail du rêve
dans la nature la nature aussi elle
travaille à sa façon le bois qui
travaille et puis surtout l'être humain
de ce point de vue là de cet élan vital
il peut travailler toute sa vie même à
la retraite même quand il est sorti et
j'adore pour finir l'anecdote du Grand
sociologue américain richardsonet sur
justement il y a beaucoup étudié le
travail alors et lui il dit pour montrer
que cette pas une question de souffrance
mais une question de vitalité il donne
l'exemple du bébé parce que le bébé s'il
fait pas un petit travail pour aller
téter le sein de sa mère ou le biberon
il meurt mais c'est un vrai effort parce
que jusque là il était nourri logé bien
tranquille il dit rien merci beaucoup
Mariette j'ai appris plein de choses
formidable chroniques et le travail
comme elle en Vita je suis sûr que ça
doit vous parler beaucoup
n'est-ce pas oui après moi je suis stupé
fait bon je viens de la gauche moi je
suis stupéfait de voir que la gauche
d'aujourd'hui qui bon ne me convient pas
forcément
renonce à cette valeur travail alors que
pour moi c'était le pilier enfin l'un
des grands piliers
de l'histoire de la gauche donc je ne
comprends pas alors on enchaîne avec
vous Brandon pour terminer cette
émission
vous
trick passe d'armes entre Aurore berger
la présidente du groupe renaissance et
la nupette sur les affaires Baillot
cadenas mais vous avez regardé un peu en
arrière qu'est-ce qu'on découvre en 1987
tout d'abord c'est la polémique
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui fait l'objet de
toutes les discussions dès la rentrée le
président du Front national est attendu
au tournant pour ses propos qu'il a tenu
quelques jours plus tôt au Grand Jury
Jean-Marie Le Pen a qualifié les
chambres à gaz de points de détails de
l'histoire de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
alors c'est un taux les général le monde
politique se déchaîne contre lui à
l'Assemblée on ne parle plus que de
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui a disparu de
l'hémicycle alors pour s'expliquer il
tient une conférence de presse mais au
lieu de présenter ses excuses Jean-Marie
Le Pen contre-attaque mais avec quel
Führer m'ont fait griller d'avoir dit
que les chambres à gaz étaient un détail
dans l'histoire de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
fainéant de croire que ce mot était
employé dans une acception péjorative
j'accuse le lobby de l'immigration
véritable syndicat anti Le Pen d'avoir
organisé et conduit contre moi ce procès
en sorcellerie et pour ses propos
polémiques Jean-Marie Le Pen sera
condamné par la justice à 1 million
200000 francs versés à des associations
antiracistes alors rentré agité on l'a
vu 1987 deux ans plus tard il y a une
nouvelle polémique qui vient perturber
nouvelle rentrée parlementaire octobre
1989 a Creil trois collégiennes sont
exclus de classe parce qu'elles refusent
de retirer leur voile ce qui aurait pu
rester un simple fait divers devient le
sujet de débat numéro 1 alors forcément
on attend la réponse du ministre de
l'éducation nationale Lionel Jospin qui
a tendu au tournant et il répond laïcité
ou tolérance
si ce produit comme ce sont produits des
cas de blocage c'est-à-dire d'enfants
qui vont à l'école notamment avec un
foulard sur la tête je préconise que les
directeurs d'établissement et les
enseignants disent à ses enfants et
alors parents qui ne doivent pas venir à
l'école dans ces conditions si il y a
blocage et si il y a refus jeudi alors
l'école doit accepter et accueillir ses
enfants un ministre ambigu vous l'avez
vu qui ne rassure pas son propre camp et
pour exprimer leur désaccord deux
députés socialistes préfèrent tourner le
sujet en dérision
partie du PS d'accord bon parti
alors plus récemment autre polémique de
rentrer grosse polémique moi je m'en
souviens j'étais pas loin du palais
Bourbon 2014 la fertévenou effectivement
un an après l'affaire Cahuzac le
secrétaire d'État au Commerce extérieur
Thomas thevenou et contraintes
démissionner 9 jours seulement après son
entrée au gouvernement Mediapart te
révélera qu'il ne payait plus ses impôts
Myriam il faut le comprendre aussi
thomas thévenou lui il souffre d'une
maladie incurable maladie que pas
reconnue par les spécialistes c'est la
phobie administrative mais il n'a pas
pour autant l'intention de démissionner
de son mandat député et vous allez voir
dans son camp on n'est pas d'accord avec
lui
nous aurions tous souhaité qu'il
démissionne de ce mandat de députés il
ne l'a pas fait nous pouvons que le
constater je trouve consternant
l'attitude de tomate et Venou je ne vois
pas aujourd'hui compte tenu de sa
situation quel est le sens de son mandat
de parlementaire et Thomas thévenou
restera député jusqu'à la fin de la
législature en 2017 et en même temps
mettra fin à sa carrière politique avant
d'être condamné pour fraude fiscal par
le par la justice il emportera quand
même avec lui l'expression phobie
administrative qu'il déposera quelques
jours plus tard à l'Institut National de
la Propriété Industrielle c'est toujours
ça j'ai envie de dire merci merci
Brandon Noiret vous regardez un peu
l'hémicycle la vie parlementaire avec
cette nouvelle donne
génération très politique et ensuite
tout ça mais moi je suis comment je ne
jette pas la pierre à Thomas thévenou
parce que j'ai la même phobie que lui
raison pour laquelle j'ai embauché un
comptable vous voyez voilà bah tant
mieux pour vous parce que ça peut
vous mener à quelques difficultés merci
les affranchis très bon week-end à vous
profitez bien ça vous regarde bien mardi
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]